ああああああ
[音楽]
yeah
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
今日は私の研究のビジョンの一つである
コグニティブ細胞部ということについてお話をしようと思います
andy clark っていう人が書いた本のタイトルにナチュラルボーン
サイボーグ州生まれながらのサイボーグというものがあります
ちょっと聞いてみたいんですけど今日お集まりいただいた方の中ですでに自分が生まれ
ながらにサイボーグだよっていうのに近くある人ってどのくらいいますか
ておいてください
こっから見るはいだとほとんどいない誰のかな
ちょっとだけですねはい
あーちょっと言い忘れたんですけどこの本翻訳された茎大先生という方は
へ
の声大学で准教授をされている方ですなので女大生でを上げてなくて大丈夫ですか
今ならまだ間に合いますかちょっと増えたよかったはいありがとうございます
えっ
でそうですね
今じゃぶり手を挙げなかった方がイメージする際ボブっていうのはおそらくこういう
感じなんじゃないかなと思います
サイボーグという言葉の定義を調べてみるとサーブ経ていくオーガニズムで自動5栽培
ティックなものと生命体王丸も織り交ぜたもの
融合したものをサイボーグという風に言うそうです
例えばどんなことができるかというと人に電子チップを埋めたりとか
また人の体の一部を機械に置き換わることによって
もっと速く走れるようになったりとか空を飛べるようになったりとかあるいは失った
手足の一部を取り戻すことができる
みたいな部分がサイボーグ技術の研究としてされています今日お話しするのはそういう
深海的に人の能力を拡張するお話ではなくて
人指摘コグニティブん
人の思考をもっと拡張するっていう話をしたいと思っています
人は無意識のうちに例えば今だと神谷ペン
あるいはコンピューターとかまたインターネットみたいなものを使って技術を使って人
の頭で行なっていたような行動を
そこで行うようになってますどんどんツールとユーザーとの間の境界というのが相葉に
なっていて
たとえばある日突然自分のスマート
が使えなくなったりとか通路を失うとあたかも自分のカードの一部を失ってしまった
みたいな感覚に陥ることがあります
これがアンディクラックが入ってた生まれながらにサイボーグであるということの五便
でした
今日お話ししたいのは彼の考えていたところよりもっと先
新しい先進技術とか ai 技術を使って人がどんな風に賢くなれるかということもお
話をします
人の恥垢を拡張する上で重要だなと私が考えているのが人の行動とかその意図を正しく
認識することです
というのも機械が今そのユーザーが何を考えてどんな行動を行っているかというのを
理解した上で初めて
機会は1アシストてすることができるからです
じゃそ人を認識するに上でどんなことがアプローチがあるかんっていうことを考えて
みると一番考えやすい人の頭を見ようという方法はたぶん脳に直接きっこつだと思い
ます
こういう装置がありましてこれ f ニールというデバイスなんですけどそれが妹脳波
とか脳の血流とかこういう装置を使っていくと今人の頭が同様に活動しているかという
ことを知ることができます
例えばこういう実験をやってみましたこれは
n バック記憶ゲームって言って
音であったりとか聞こえてくる音と光っている場所が前回あります n 回前と同じ
だったら同じをクリック
という風にやっていくゲームでそれを1回前とか
2回目3回目4回前てどんどん難易度を上げていくという記憶力のゲームですこれを
fe 留守をつけた状態でやってもらっています
ワンバック問題
はそんなに難しくない前回のやつと同じがどうかだけなので
でも2バックとかの問題を解いてもらうと確かに人の記憶に関わるような脳の部分が
アクティブになっているっていうことがこの装置を使うと分かります
3バックとかめちゃくちゃ難しくてどんどんどんどん人の高頭が活性化されてるんです
ね
この子実験は面白かったのはフォーク問題解いてもらうと急に脳の活性がストンと落ち
たんですよ
これ何でだろうなーって考えて一つの仮説としてはこの人は自分は頑張ってんだけど
動画元区の諦めてしまってうまく
子記憶
することができもんだということができなかったんじゃないかというのがあります
例えばこの人の場合だと3バック問題ぐらいのレベルが今のすんの自分の脳を活性化
記憶力を高めていくにはベストがないドンということがわかります
という風にこういう高度なセンサーを使えば人の頭のことがわかります
ただ難しいのはこの政策を実験風景なんですけどこうやって脳に頭にいっぱいセンサー
を刺しさして
する必要があって sf っぽいというかこれ
未来の映像としてなんとなくありそうな感じするんですけどこれをにしよう生活で使う
か
っていうとなかなか使えないですね
装置もめちゃくちゃ高い高級車とか買えるような値段の総科のでなかなか芸術的じゃ
ない
[音楽]
その一方で反対側のアプローチ何があるかというと人の体の動きをモーションセンサー
によってキャプチャするということが研究されています
例えば得てスマートフォンであったりとか日アラブデバイスに入っている
加速度とか角速度センサーを使うと人がどんな報道してるか
歩いてるとか座っているとか寝てるとかっていう行動が認識できます
じゃあこれで十分かというとそうじゃないんですよね
これだと例えばへ
そうですね読書しているとかテレビを見ているとか
人の頭を使う行動って大体は座って行う行動らしいカードの大きな動きを伴わないんで
こういうセンサーでうまく認識することができません
ということでその両極端からだいたい真ん中ぐらいのアプローチを
私は研究テーマとして扱っていてそこで人の行動認識ています
具体的に言うと目は口ほどに物を言うという言葉があります年人の目線
眼球運動を見ているとそして今どんな行動をしているかとか何考えてるのかっていうの
がついてできるんじゃ
ないかっていうのが僕の研究テーマの稼ぐ大きな仮説です
今日はそうやって人の目を見るとどんなことが分かるか人が何をどのように行動して
いるというのが分かる
それがどんなトピックがあってどんなアプリケーションにつながっているかっていう例
を紹介していきます
初めに何をしているかということの認識です
何をしている感じです上で私が着目したのは人の瞬きでした
例えば行動とか人も心的状態によってまばたきの回数が品
その感覚っていうのが大きく変わって変わっているというのが心理学の実験で明らかに
なっています
ちょっとじゃあ2つ目の質問したいんですけど
この場合は読書本を読んでいる活動と会話人と話してる活動は滝の回数が増えるのは
どっちでしょう
読書しているときの方がまばたきすると思うと手を挙げてください
乱人回避できません
はいじゃあ今度は会話してる方が増えると思う人ってあげてください
こっちの方が多い手を挙げた方正解です
実験したところ人が集中してるときっていうのはまばたきの回数が減って瞬きも入って
一定になるんですけど会話してたりするとと瞬きの回数が増えますしそれも不規則に
なるっていう研究の結果が出ました
こういうのを使って例えば google glass のセンサーの一部をハック
すると人が瞬き車載ミングっていうのを取れるっていうのをアプリケーションを作り
ました
この右上にある数字がまばたきのカウンターですね
アブだけをするとそれが1ずつ上がっていく5瞬きをしたかってのを記録します
本読んでたりとかいろんなシーンでも使える
あとは別のセンサーで眼電位を計測できるメガネを使うと同じに瞬きが取れます
ちょっと面白いなと思うのは誰か実は人間の目って黒名は合併はせで反対側が網膜母が
マイナスに帯電しているらしくて目を動かすと
上を見るとこのあたりが+
逆にしたが-2
偏っていくらしいですねそういう電気の電場の絵がんレーンの違う使って電極を3つ
放て徒歩でこにつけると目をどう動かしたかってのがわかります
例えばこれがそのでもで上側の線が垂直方向
したが水平方向のがん転移ずですそれを見ていると右を左と金を動かしたりとか目を
パチパチ瞬きしたという行動が取れます
それを使ってさっきのあの会話とか読書とかみたいな行動を
システムが認識をしています
今だと人と話しているので
talking っていうのがスゴシステム上で見えています
こうやって会話とか読書みたいな行動含んだ行動が認識できています
こういう行動を認識できるとどんないいことがあるかということについてお話をします
この研究のもと頭を使って作ったアプリケーションが新四兄弟アプリケーションでした
これは何かというといろんなウェアラブルセンサーとか
各種 web サービスから集めた情報行動ログを使って人も心の状態を推定すると
いうアプリケーションです
例えばスノキ論が落ち込んでるときは普段より活動の量が減るとかっていうふうに活動
と高の状態は相互に相関があるということは分かっているので今みたいにどれだけ人が
歩いたかこれは簡単ですね
でどれだけ文字を読んだかっていうのは瞬きか分かる
あとはどれだか岩坂みたいな社会的活動量認知的活動両親た
活動量を計測して機械学習会技術を使うと今自分がどのくらい
気分がすぐれているかというのが分かるピュアプリケーションです
これを使うと今これは心音て値で表示していて例えばその
熱が出て
調子が悪い時よくすることはまず体温を測って自分が今何度かってくを知ると思うん
ですけどこういうイメージで自分が今どれぐらい気持ちの浮き沈みがあってそれを足せ
ば熱が38度あったそれを見せるとあ38で休んだほうがいいよっていうふうに教えて
もらえるように一つの軸があれば自分の心の状態を伝えやすい
っていう下で作ったアプリケーションで
ん
この裏側はたとえばさっきみたいに新大陸活動量人指摘活動量
社会的活動量っていうものがスコアリングされて言ってこれを見ることによって今自分
が足りてない活動を見つけて気持ちを兼ねることができる
ティアプリケーションです
あとこれはまあ完全に余談なんですけどずっとずまばたきの研究していると自分で
まばたきをコントロールするのがうまくなるっていうメリットがあります
これあの瞬きしたタイミングで鳥が飛ぶっていうゲームを作りまして結構やってるん
ですけど
多分瞬きを使ってゲームをプレイする大会っていうのがあったらおそらく僕は世界一に
なると思います
っていうのが何を知っていう活動でした今度はじゃあそれをもっと深く見ていって
どんなコードどのように行動しているかっていうのを認識するお話をします
その例の一つ法がコレですねさっき認識たのが
人が買っ読書しているということを認識してましたけど
読書をしているということだけじゃなくてそれがどういうスピードでどれくらいの単語
を読んでいるかみたいな
何がどのようにっていう部分も認識できます
今この人が端から順番に文字を読んでます
その時の細い目の動き例えば右右右右へ行って開業
家右右右開業みたいな動きをさっきのガンで計測すると
これを機械学習会技術に投げると人が選んだ単語すっていうのを推定することができ
ます
でこの二システムなんですけど今端から選んで走ってたけど面白いところは
別にあのディスプレイ上で読む必要はなくて例えば普通の本を読んでいたりとか
あるいはこれを使って部屋の中じゃなくて
粗糖とかいろんな場所でもこの眼鏡をかけて1日生活していると自分が一体どのくらい
もう
嬢呼んだんだろうっていうのが計測することができます
deko あとでアプリケーションに持って帰ると
恭一にしてどういう時間帯にどれぐらいのスピードでどれだけものを選んだとかって
いうのが振り返ることができるわけです
このアプリケーションの背景バックランドとしては万歩計のリーディング読書版を作り
たいっていうのがありました
これマン合計言って万歩計になぞらえた名前をつけたんですけど
我々の研究してはマンゴー系っていうふうに読んでます
で万歩計をつけているとなぜか自然と普段の個数が活動量が上がっていくのと同じよう
にマンゴー系を使っていくとなぜか普段よりちょっとずつちょっとずつ
文字を読む習慣がつくっていうアプリケーションです
例えば人は食べた物によってできている人のカードを食べた物によってできると思うん
ですけど
同じように人が頭っていうのは読んだものによってできているっていう風に考えが鳴り
ます
例えば読書習慣と後読書週間と1の語彙力とか
またその人の抱く力あとは認知的思考力理解力みたいなものにも相関があるか調べてる
ので普段より本を読む習慣がこれつけば人はもっと賢くなるわけですね
あとはこれは別のセンサーでさっきの眼球運動だけじゃなくてもっと
どの場所を見ているかもう推定するようなセンサーを使うとどんなことができるかと
いうと一例だけ紹介すると英語文書を読んでいるときに自分がわからないなぁと思った
単語は考えだと思うだろう単語っていうのを
システムが自動的に識別することができます
これを使うと例えばはそうですね本を読んだり英語のウェブページを読んでいるときに
自分がわからない単語が自動的に翻訳されたりとかあとは読み終わった後にあなたが今
復讐すべき単語っていうのを自動でリストアップしてくれる
こんなシステムを作ることができます
これは今ドイツで研究している開発しているシステムの一つでそういう技術を色々
組み合わせて未来の電子教科書を作ろうということをやっています
生徒が読んでいてどの部分につまずきを感じてどこがおもしろいと感じたかっていうの
を
支店アイトラッカーを使ってますあとは赤外線カメラを使って人の顔の音頭をとってい
ます
みたいなものから計測して今ふわっと出たみたいに教科書を動的に新しいものを表示し
たりとか
っていう教科書があると
未来の教育はきっと変わると思います
詳しい事はお話はしないんですけどざっくりいうと人の目の動き
あとは顔の温度から例えば中止時間であったりとか読み返しであったりとか
こういう情報を抽出してそこから興味と軽い会というものを継承しています
今日はそういうお話人の行動を専心するセンシングすることによって人の例えば
ストレスコントロールであったりとか
人の学習っていうものを機械が支援することができるという話をしました
最後にじゃあ今直近で作れたアプリケーションじゃなくてもうちょっと先の話
どんなことにつながるかという話をして今日の話を終わろうと思います
近い将来にシングル it というポイントに我々は
たしますこれはざっくり言うと機械が ai がドンドン賢くなって言っていつか人の
うち脳を追い抜く瞬間だと言われています
じゃこの瞬間が来たらもう人は働かなくていいのかとか人の仕事はどんどん捉えていく
のかとかいろんな質問があると思うんですけど私は必ずしもこれは正しいとは思ってい
ません
っていうのをなぜかというとこの頭は人間が進化するということを考慮してない
つだからですね
で今私がやっているコミュニティ部サイボーグこの研究によって人がどんどんへ愛の力
を使って賢くなればきっと
ai が賢くなるにしたがってそれがかさん的にあるいは
掛け算的にドンドン賢くなって人はもっと
クリエイティブなこと知的作業がもっとはかどるようなことができるようになっていく
と考えています
こういうビジョンに基づいて研究をしています
以上ですご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]
[音楽]